yeah i think part of it is your content
creation the other part of is like
you know i used to as simple as
responding in the comments like you'd be
surprised
comics don't even respond ever
like how i respond to usually two or
three comics
on each platform and i don't i can't do
it as much as i used to but let's find
two or three on facebook two or three on
instagram two or three on youtube two or
three on twitter
and that just lets people know that i'm
not just a piece of them i'm not a cog
in a machine i'm a real person
reading that now the drawback of that is
you read a lot of comments and they're
not all
positive but i i talk to my audience i
go live we talk directly to them
and it's not always here by this here by
that hereby just heard by that like
re-establish uh you know kind of like a
relationship
and that's it's as simple as commenting
back to them hey what do you guys think
of this shirt and then listening
like um my audience is
great right i i test you know now for me
it's a lot easier because i have patreon
and that's like the core fan base these
people are the ones i know are going to
buy something if it's
viable you know i'll throw hey what do
you guys think of this shirt that'd be
like yeah kev
drop it and sometimes they'll be like
this is the worst
ever don't sell this i believe i'd say
that yeah
dreams never die shirt i should have
asked them because
dreams never sell so you know
uh but that's been built up over over
time
okay cool yeah i believe they they'll be
honest they're being honest for sure
yeah yeah oh porcelain doll i see yeah
yeah
yeah because even that on that merch
game like you you would
you know fly across the country for a
hundred bucks but then sell fifteen
hundred dollars
in merch you know the merch game is no
joke
yeah man that's how i got by i remember
you know that story you're talking about
was in augusta i got 150 bucks
to get paid and i remember when i was
flying i was like this really doesn't
make any sense
but i had you know fifteen hundred
dollars worth of merch in my duffel bag
and i sold out so you know back then
most of my shows were free the church
would bring me
and cover my flight hotel and then the
show would be free they'd take an
offering or whatever
um and you know my currency was was
merchandise so
um i wouldn't say that i'm a great merch
salesman
uh but i try to give my people who
support me something about i'm actually
working on a new
uh thing to launch at the top of the
year that kind of coincides
that with the app but at the time that
was my
currency was like merch because you know
people were like well i had a great
time and i didn't pay for a ticket i got
30 bucks let me you know let me buy so
they might not even wear it you know i
used to sell dvds at this time
uh and when people had a great time
they'd be like let me buy everything you
got i buy three of these dvds
you know and one shirt you know so
that's like 60 70
bucks and that's better or more than
you know a ticket price yeah i'm i'm
seeing um
and i'm thinking you're saying the app
and you have the sound stage and you
have the studio
and you have all these podcasts and like
let me um
i don't want to jump into uh fan
questions here as well
but um i want to selfishly ask this one
and pick your brain a little bit more
because i really do feel like
we're on to something special here at
hot breath and in your
your instincts on your own experience
like
we have you know we have the weekly
podcast we do these q as we have the
facebook group we have the membership
group
we have this youtube channel like what
you seem
you started off with one and then you
built out but where do you see like
how can how can we keep pushing the
envelope forward we kind of have this
baseline
and you're saying be consistent but is
your instinct saying
even just try this or that and just
start to kind of mix it up a little bit
yeah i mean i i try
so many things i mean literally so many
things um
sometimes that's also realizing that
you're not good at one
you know like yeah vine i was like i
tried
some of the worst vines ever are on my
page i'm almost
glad that platform died just so you
can't go and search
how bad my vines used to be tick-tock
i didn't perfect it but i found that my
dad jokes worked on there so
i think it's about like i'll throw it
against the wall and even clubhouse
which is kind of an emerging
merging app i i i dip my toes in the
water there
because you just never know who you're
going to connect with on what platform
but i also know part of that is
realizing it's hard to
be uh i'll use the term dominant
on all platforms right with with you
know specific content for each so
i you know kind of focus the most
patreon is my most important app
by far because that's my direct line to
my audience
uh but that required me to build a good
youtube page youtube facebook
instagram now thank the lord you can
basically post the same video on those
but you need to take the extra time and
actually post it there's a lot of people
still posting
the link from their instagram on twitter
nobody's watching that
and no one's clicking that link you have
to post
that video on twitter and cut it down in
two minutes and 20 seconds or whatever
you know so that's part of it just first
making the content
uh and posting it natively um but
the way i kind of see it social media is
my job it's my
responsibility to be uh aware of all the
apps what's popping what's
dropping whatever and know what my
strengths are like periscope was a great
app for me because i'm long-winded i
could talk and talk and talk
so me and my audience when i used to be
driving to work for an hour and a half i
used to talk to them
four or five times a week for 45 minutes
for like a year
two years almost three years you know
and i only really stopped that when i
started patreon because
when i started patreon and i quit that
job because i didn't have an hour and a
half
in my day where i was like i couldn't do
anything but so many of my fans
were like bro we used to be up in there
having a great it was only like a
and this is what i need people to
understand
my periscope i never was big on
periscope
but we used to have the the 95s what our
my fan base was called
when we're on periscope 100 200 people
in there
we would be having the we would have the
time of our lives
in there so it wasn't about being viral
or crazy it was just about connecting
with my audience
every day we never had a crazy amount of
people in there and it wasn't about that
it was about
you know having a good time with my with
my fans and family
and them 200 people they came to patreon
their stage crew they're they're people
who are buying the tickets to keep your
distance
but that's years of free content where i
wasn't asking for anything we was just
hanging out having a good time and i
still really struggled to ask for
anything even to buy stuff but i
realized if i want to continue to do
this i gotta promote
you know my my uh
my business ventures so that's why i
promote but if i could find a way to
monetize
without promoting i would do it wow
yeah me too and prime even might
we just got a super chat so thanks for i
know that then gave you two dollars joe
we out here we made it you did now
dabbed and raised the roof in the same
interview
we have got to get you we got to do the
world you got to you got to bring
one dance that's been released in the
last three years
elisa whoa joel
your dog on raise the roof threw off my
train of thought i don't even know what
i was gonna say my bad man yeah
hey hot brother and sister if you love
comedy as much as we do here at hot
breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath verse and then watch
more videos to get even more comedy tips